hey Gary how's it going it's dom Gary
that wanted to say hello and ask you
this as you know I've talked to you
about it before I'm working on building
an app with one of my business partners
and while i'm in charge of adoption the
app is probably six months away from
actually having a working working
prototype so what would you suggest i
start doing now to make sure that I'm
building it up so that when it does come
to adoption time and the app is released
we have plenty of users that are going
to be using it thanks a lot Gary Tom
first of all good to see you thanks for
your hard core following ship over the
last year's years and can't quantify it
but I know we've been jamming hard for
multiple years um I'm gonna give you a
really good answer I and this is the
answer that's going to work for
everybody no matter whether you have an
app or you sell clocks content content
hunt clockwork huh content content
content content I think you need to put
up so let's say you're putting out a
fitness app or a Productivity app for
time management you then need to create
time management com which is not
available but daily time management com
or something and putting out content
around the genre you need to create the
content portal on medium or your own
blog or on rebel Mouse which I believe
in clearly linked it up and and you need
to you need to basically create content
to get like-minded people in that are
you know you come out with Fitness
stallion yours is a fitness utility app
and then boom you've got this audience
and then when the app comes out you
pound them with it and it comes out you
need to gather people in a place that
are like-minded or most likely to use
the app and then when the time's right
shout to them jabbing and then right
hooking
Oh